welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of loki
episode 5 journey into mystery of course
a nod to the original comic run that
introduced loki and thor fitting for an
episode filled with easter eggs to
marvel comics but also enough hatches
egyptian icons and smoke monsters to
haunt me from the series that got me
into this kind of stuff lost which
hopefully loki will do better than with
expectation management
hey let's break down this episode frame
by frame for all the interesting hidden
details because this episode's got a lot
of them hey and a reminder that you can
get our lucky inspired merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
like this loki out of time shirt which
directly supports us here at new
rockstars we open on the tva timeline
screen with location showing vormir the
planet that held the soul stone infinity
war in in-game seoul south korea
zimbabwe and oak island nova scotia
maybe a nod to the oak island treasure
the theorized knights templar treasure
believed to be buried on oak island that
people think might contain the holy
grail the ark of the covenant
shakespearean manuscripts and the camera
nauseatingly flips upside down and then
rotates as the chrono monitor room back
wall just dissolves into the time keeper
elevator doors which then dissolve into
their chamber where we now reverse the
rotation so the frame rotates
counterclockwise toward the severed
timekeeper android head a true journey
in the mystery this opening shot is
reflecting how each of these settings
have been in their own ways smoke
screens for some deeper truth beyond
them much like how the final shot of
this episode is yet another literal
smoke screen peeling back to reveal some
other truth beyond but even that might
contain another secret twist that i'll
talk about later but notice how this
series keeps focusing on that one
central timekeeper more than the other
two almost as if that android could be a
primary one specifically designed in its
creator's image we enter the void the
tva's supposed dumping ground we passed
the lighthouse of alexandria one of the
seven wonders of the ancient world now
this void also contains the pyramids of
giza another ancient wonder and with the
hanging gardens of babylon showing up in
eternals that makes three out of seven
wonders in the mcu this year this
lighthouse also bookends the lit tower
which maybe is the lighthouse in the
final shot and trailer footage tells us
that that setting has a library inside
it perhaps another source of
illumination next on the left is dr
strange's sanctum sanctorum i would not
want to live in a reality with those
guys pruned from it maybe there was some
past conflict between the sorcerer
supreme and the tda over who really
should monitor the multiverse now as we
pass avengers tower we realize written
on it is not avengers or a or stark but
king as in king enterprises the company
tony stark sold this tower to in the
comics it's run by mr gryffin revealed
to be kang the conqueror the latest clue
that kang could be our man behind the
curtain after all to the left is another
building if you look closely at the top
of it is labeled ken park 2018 it looks
like suggesting this whole void could be
made up of pieces of histories that kang
has conquered similar to his kingdom of
chronopolis 2018 would be right after
the snap which could be when kang
enterprises moved into that tower notice
how trotting around on the ledges are
these indigo bird things with their
spherical heads that hover over their
necks they run on five little hot dog
feet all over the void no clue what
these are but this episode was written
by rick and morty writer tom kaufman who
wrote the season 3 froopyland clone
death episode with a similarly bonker's
pocket reality filled with goofy
creatures and an immature exile who
crowns himself king and then finally
some answers what is this place where
are we who are you is is the void that's
goliath and we're his lunch come on
goliath is a trans-temporal entity from
the marvel comics who takes the form of
this kind of carnivorous smoke he rivals
the time empire of kang the conqueror
and kang uses the entity of tempus to
trap eliath in eternal battle so that
kang can expand his rule and it just so
happens that ravana rinslayer is also
part of this 1993 storyline so i'm
wondering if in this case kang may be
using goliath as a guard dog as he works
behind him to assemble his kingdom
renslayer explains when we prune a
branched reality it's impossible to
destroy all its matter basically the
branch timeline isn't reset
it's transferred to a
a void at the end of time yeah rinse
layer is appealing to the law of
conservation of mass that says matter
can neither be destroyed nor created
only transferred not that the laws of
physics really matter that much on the
show but rensselaer claims to not know
who created the tva and based on her
later scene with b15 she truly could be
a memory-wiped variant same as the rest
of them but this being rinsed layer the
primary love interest in the comics too
kang i wonder if she could be a teacher
or an admin from that fdr high school
that caught the eye of a young nathaniel
richards maybe even a teacher that he
had a crush on and once he grew up to be
kang he went back in time to trap her in
this phony temporal law office so that
she would catch the bullies and class
clowns who threaten his utopia back in
the void is a three-masted wooden ship
with light boats on the deck this could
be the santa maria columbus's flagship
that struck a reef off the coast of
present-day haiti sunk and its wreckage
was never recovered they passed this
huge flying saucer another aerial
phenomenon that could have just been
spotted on earth and then pruned and
then they passed what looks like red
skull's spinning rocket from the first
captain america film which was based on
the real-life german folk wolf
tribifugal fighter plane built during
the later years of world war ii and then
this row of giant bald head statues
partially buried in the ground kind of
looks like the big head sculpture in
canmore in alberta canada the home
province of that son of a [ __ ] james
howlett aka logan aka wolverine who did
you think i was gonna say go [ __ ]
yourself so these loki variants are
classic loki richard e grant dressed in
loki's classic attire from the early
comics boastful loki whose clothes look
like the dark rain era of loki he wields
a mjolnir made from a piston and a piece
of a train rail kid loki who carries
loki's levatin sword from norse
mythology and alligator loki and loki
asks them but have you thought of using
a template oh the one thing that could
easily get us out of here yes they're
all over the place right guys
fine ah loki gator blinks as gators do
side by side but it plays like an eye
roll here i love it and they pass a big
pile of lunch trays which must be ones
from the tva cafeteria like rather than
cleaning and reusing them they just
prune them all so wasteful and you know
these are from the tva because among
that pile are also boxes of boku fruit
juice hey by the way loosen your hair
can be a bummer two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
i know guys in my life that are stressed
out about that but with keeps it is
easier and more affordable to get
treatment for your hair loss and help
you keep the hair that you have keeps
offers generic versions of the only two
fda approved hair loss products out
there but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy though you never have to go
into a doctor's office with keeps you
get 24 7 access to a doctor who designs
the best plan for you they offer other
helpful tools and services including the
tracking tools so you can monitor your
progress find out why keeps has more 5
star reviews than any of its competitors
and nearly 100 000 men trust keeps for
their hair loss prevention medication so
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com new
rockstars or click the link in the
description to receive 50 off your first
order that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash new
rockstars kid loki reveals what his
nexus event was i killed full yikes
perhaps kid loki's thor died when that
trick that thor mentioned in ragnarok
led him to bleed out this one time with
real children he
he transformed himself into a snake and
he knows that i love snakes so i went to
pick up the snake to admire it and he
transformed back into himself and he was
like yeah it's me and he stabbed me
we were eight at the time then there is
a giant helmet of the ant-man villain
yellow jacket last seen with his damaged
resizer shrinking him down to nothing
but perhaps still alive somewhere in the
quantum realm this recalls the shocking
imagery of ant-man's giant corpse strewn
across the post-apocalyptic landscape
and old man logan and then yes the
thanos copter one of the goofiest toy
pushing moments from marvel comics with
end game lightly referencing it when
thanos rotated the sword now presumably
pruned from some alternate timeline
though this could mean some alternate
timeline thanos was pruned here and then
maybe consumed by eliath there's also a
huge warhead maybe some stolen nuke that
were it not pruned would have started a
global nuclear war and then they enter
this hatch that we get a better look of
later with text written on it in hindi
in the circle that translates to a and
then the yellow right and on the right
pravesh dwar entry door and then to the
green on the left sabdahan vishala
careful poisonous so maybe this is a
hatch for an indian nuclear facility or
their nuclear submarine the ins arihant
then a great floorboard gag sinking down
to show us what is buried underneath
more lunch trays and silverware a buried
mjolnir and trying to get to it a thor
frog in a jar marked 365 a nod to throg
in thor comic issue 365. i love how you
can hear him grunting as he throws
himself against the glass just like how
thor did in his cell in the first
avengers movie
their hideout is a customized bowling
alley looks like circus lanes written on
the back wall there kid loki has made a
throne out of what looks like a santa
land from a mall or did santa get pruned
too there's a space mission pinball game
and then a polybius arcade box this was
an urban legend from the portland area
in the 80s and 90s that claimed the
government could have rigged games
called polybius for hypnosis and mind
control uses rentslayer and missed
minutes work together to try to stall
sylvie find loki find the man behind the
curtain and kill him yes the man behind
the curtain of course a direct nod to
the wizard of oz which this tva mystery
creator is clearly based on but the way
miss minutes picks up these non-verbal
cues from rentslayer is just another
reason to think something more will be
revealed about this character back in
the bowling alley they listened to the
mike flowers pops cover of wonderwall an
intentionally hokey cover of that
annoyingly sincere song by oasis that
like that one [ __ ] at the party in
college who brought his guitar has to
play they drink roxy wine roxxx probably
got it from roxcart classic loki and
boastful loki both have huge chalices
but they gave loki a small one kid loki
sips hi-c ecto cooler between them
there's a campfire of charred bowling
pins and beside alligator loki is a book
the mystery and lore of monsters by cjs
thompson a rare 1930 survey of human
deformities and monster lore alligator
loki calls [ __ ] on boastful loki's
tale of defeating cap and iron man
getting all the infinity stones well at
least my nexus event wasn't eating the
wrong neighbor's cat alligator loki goes
right for his hand just like how he
later captain hook's president loki and
classic loki explains how he survived
thanos i cast a projection of myself so
real
even the mad titan believed it
then
hid as inanimate debris this is crazy
the writers apparently worked into
classic loki's backstory a fan theory
that channels like ours discussed back
in 2018 that during loki's death scene
in infinity war a floating piece of
debris in the background looked like
loki with his big curved horns making us
think that loki might have faked his
death at the time a theory that i was
forced to apologize for i just look
forward to the 2024 ghost rider movie
where mephisto says agatha's devils in
the details come back was a reference to
him classic loki says he landed on a
remote planet and stay there in
isolation
in solitude
for a long
long time yeah he says he got lonely and
tried to leave and then he got arrested
i wonder if his lonely planet could have
been vormir referenced earlier this
episode but also back in episode two
where the screen listed a nexus event on
vormir in the year
2301 which would have been hundreds of
years after that moment with thanos but
i do have another theory on this guy
just more on him later they meet a new
loki gang led by president loki who's a
reference to the 2016 vote loki
miniseries in which loki runs for
president pledging that he's not afraid
to lie to people but then there's this
other bearded one who was the same one
who was labeled variant l 8914 back in
episode two another one has a helmet
made of silverware probably gotten from
all those tva lunch trays and then
another with a helmet with a bike
handlebar sylvie who pruned herself
earlier awakens on a school bus and
enchants a branch of goliath getting a
quick vision of what it's guarding the
rock ring suspended at the end of time
that i pointed out in trailer footage
with a castle and a lit tower now this
castle does look a bit like a darker
version of neuschwanstein in germany
which is an inspiration to many fantasy
castles moebius drives up in a skinny's
pizza car to save her notice how the
plate number is jira in w-1d so maybe
like growled maybe a nod to mark
grunwald the marvel comics writer of
many of these influencing titles that in
the comics the tva staff was all
designed to look like specifically
mobius he actually might have cameoed in
the courtroom banner in the show behind
them is a suspension bridge that looks
like a cross between the towers of san
francisco's two major bridges both
golden gate bridge and oakland bay
bridge and then there's also a sign for
wrightville theater screening the movie
oswald and the martian now a different
similar town wrightsville pennsylvania
showed up in the nexus event in 1832 but
this movie might be referring to mars a
1930 short animated by walt disney for
universal starring oswald the rabbit
mobius drives past the pyramids of giza
and the sphinx but notice the sphinx has
not lost its nose perhaps that's why it
was pruned because it was supposed to
lose it and yes a reminder that the
pyramids of the spanx do show up as
trophies in kang's chronopolis if that
ends up being the case but to the right
is a structure that before i thought was
stonehenge but in this clear footage i
don't think it's stonehenge it has these
greek columns to it so i don't know
maybe some ancient greek structure maybe
the white house after it was burned down
in 1812 i don't know i've been going on
a historical kick while i'm watching the
show the loki's all bigger you led the
wolves to our door we prefer snakes to
wolves i've eaten both they die just the
same snakes and wolves could be nods to
yerman gander the great snake and van
rear the wolf or fenris and the mcu both
of whom are loki's offspring in norse
mythology alligator loki bites off
president loki's hand causing him to let
out a very long screen if you listen to
it all the way through
classic loki gets them out of there by
conjuring up duplicates of themselves
with duplicate kid loki tossing
alligator loki and one of the others
also known as thor and loki's get help
maneuver get help
classic the uss eldridge drops into the
void this was a real-life world war ii
era ship that was believed to be part of
a debunk conspiracy theory known as the
philadelphia experiment in which people
claimed it was given an invisibility
shield and people thought it vanished
the teams regroup at a barber shop where
they roast one of those bird creature
things and interestingly mobius didn't
remember there ever being an alligator
loki perhaps another clue that there
just could be multiple mobiuses
meanwhile loki and sylvia chat outside
it's cold
frost giants aren't supposed to get cold
so loki must have been conjuring up that
blanket just so they could snuggle
smooth
one of the birds climbs this tank this
is the chrysler tv8 a nuclear-powered
tank that was designed by chrysler in
the 50s to be deployed against the ussr
but thank god was never actually put
into production but maybe this came from
a timeline where this did actually
happen probably with horrible results
and the distance is the dark aster ronin
ship from the guardians of the galaxy
there also looks like an oil platform
maybe this is the deepwater horizon so
loki asks mobius what will you do at the
tva
burn it to the ground
thanks for the spark
uh call back to loki's promise all the
way back in the first episode i'm gonna
burn this place to the ground now on
this landscape you can see the head of
the living tribunal that's the
three-headed cosmic judge of all the
multiverse i don't know what timeline
its head would have come from but i do
like how loki and sylvie stand in front
of it as they face eliath almost as if
they are now on the side of justice in
this noble fight and a little later in
the scene there is in the background a
crashed helicarrier with a hydra logo
perhaps this came from a reality where
project insight was successful and hydra
no longer needed to hide itself loki
waves his flaming sword to try to
distract goliath but it does not work
making him remember what classic loki
said earlier the blades are worthless in
the face of a loki's sorcery
they stunt a magical potential so loki
realizes he must drop this sword and
join sylvie in her enchantment but they
get some major backup from the old man
[Music]
natalie holt's music is incredible she
actually said she used a 32 voice choir
for all the vocals here and you might
have noticed right in this moment it
samples richard wagner's norse inspired
riot of the valkyries
he casts this epic illusion of asgard
which at first looks a lot like the
emerald city in the green light there
but i love its detail down to those
statues of warriors past on all the
edifices but the illusion fades and
classic loki gets consumed though notice
how he did have some green sorcery
glowing in his hands but then just lets
it fade the final second as he laughs
with glee making me wonder if this guy
could have pulled an obi-wan and let
himself get taken here so that he could
respawn in a new form hold that thought
i'm almost there because sylvie and loki
enchant eliath and open the gate to
beyond the void revealing the castle
with the lit tower on the rock ring at
the end of time who will they find there
well yes this series has done a lot to
point to kang the conqueror because sure
why else would you include ravana rinse
layer and eliath and kang enterprises
and all these chronopolis parallels just
to completely avoid the upcoming mcu big
bad that connects these dots but hey
we've been led astray before right so
you could make the case for other
possible big bads like doctor doom maybe
an evilest loki maybe some version of
miss minutes or simply what if we were
to just follow the theme of the man
behind the curtain a weasley old man the
creator of the timekeepers in the comics
he who remains and i will leave you with
this folks notice as they approach that
castle a piece of debris floats up now
at first i thought this could have been
a ship but even if it is just debris
classic loki just confirmed that
floating debris can sometimes be a loki
in disguise after he fakes his death
classic loki for some reason passed up
mobius's offer to leave the void and
then he stayed and showed off an insane
level of sorcery sorcery that he spent
who knows how long refining and then
could have faked his death in that
moment and then lured these variants to
his castle where he reveals himself as
he who remains an original loki who
survived and built the timekeepers and
the tva in order to control the
multiverse with this ultimate illusion
whether or not you believe that or if
you think it's kang or someone else you
gotta admit that truly would be a
classic loki move
comment down below with your theories as
we head into this finale episode and
another reminder to support this channel
by checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars i'll see
you next week for the finale thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you